that is so busted okay that is so much
one Counter-Strike mystery has kept us
up at night for years who is Foon for
those out of the loop thune was and
maybe still is a legendary
Counter-Strike Source player known for
his Godlike movement his iconic frag
movie Foon too much for z-block has over
9 million views and spawn some of
Gaming's greatest sound bites
but that video came out over a decade
ago and we still don't know who phone is
or if he was scripting or not there are
plenty of theories out there and some
streamers who even claim to know Foon
been him used to hang out all the time
he didn't even put me in this I don't
know like his behalf were really
nuts but
they probably could have done it without
stripping but honestly maybe we were
never meant to know the real answer it's
cause the movement guys